prohibition played a large role in
building what I call the federal penal
state it was the era the nation's first
war on drugs no simple repeal may get us
out of this current crisis of mass
incarceration we need to rethink this
penal and criminal approach toward drug
addiction
hi I'm Nicolas booth recent TV and today
we're talking with historian Lisa McGurk
she's the author most recently of the
war on alcohol prohibition and the rise
of the American state what are the
biggest misconceptions about how
prohibition affected American society
the misconception is that it was a
complete and total failure prohibition
did fill was one of the greatest public
policy failures in our history it's the
only constitutional amendment that was
passed to be rescinded just less than 15
years later but the reality is that that
failure has led us to lose sight of the
many long-term legacies that prohibition
left us with and in particular the role
of prohibition in terms of state
building and you find that when you say
state bill well prohibition played a
large role in building what I call the
federal penal state this was the moment
where the federal government really
beefed up its role in criminal justice
in crime control it was the era of the
nation's first war on drugs prior to
Prohibition the federal state it was a
bit player in crime control and this is
the time where wrote the Prohibition
experience and the war on crime that
resulted because of the collateral
violence of organized crime rings led to
a new and permanent role for the federal
government as a backstop to local and
state law enforcement never lost it
during Prohibition I mean part of the
interesting thing about the books as you
contrast parts of the country where
prohibition was really not enforced and
it was widely floated and then in other
places where it was it was never
uniformly enforced but it was enforced
against particular types of people how
is it that a place like New York it
wasn't as tightly enforced as say in
parts of the south talk a little bit
about why there were differences and and
how
Plato it was a national law in that way
the Volstead Act was a uniform national
law but every state had its own
enforcement code and those codes were
different so some states were more
restrictive than others
and where there was a lot of dry
sentiment enforcement was taken very
seriously
leading to rising rates of incarceration
overcrowded prisons in places like New
York there was an enormous amount of wet
sentiment this was an immigrant
industrial large city cosmopolitan place
and so already in 1923 New York
rescinded its state enforcement law that
basically said we're weak they said
we're not in the business of enforcing
this if you want it forces up to the
federal government we're not going to
become involved in but then I talked
about in North Carolina and Virginia
where who were the people when
Prohibition was being enforced who were
the people who were feeling the pain the
people who were feeling the pain were
largely poor marginal violators
working-class men and women whether it
be African in Virginia its African
Americans in places like Richmond and
city centers poor whites in rural areas
but overwhelmingly whether you're
looking at Virginia North Carolina
Kentucky or Los Angeles it's where it
was mexican-americans it's largely
groups that had already been identified
in public discourse as kind of breeders
of criminality so marginal groups that
were already already discriminate
against receive the bulk of so it I mean
it really is like a not a dry run I
guess a wet run for the war on drugs
I one can think about there are so many
parallels between the war on out what I
call the war on alcohol and the later
war on drugs one could argue that in
some ways it served as a dress rehearsal
for the later war on drugs in the sense
that it was a it was it was shorter
lived it was more controversial and so
federal officials learned from that
experience and at the end of prohibition
did not remove themselves from
regulating other narcotic substances but
move forward in new campaigns and new
directions and it's of course the war on
alcohol and the war on drugs were
symbiotic campaigns it's something which
is a story not widely known but those
two campaigns emerge together they had
the same shared set of logics many of
the same individuals were involved in
both campaigns so for example the father
of alcohol prohibition Richmond Hobson
who was the highest-paid lecture for the
anti-saloon League in the 1920s however
he moved increasingly to turn his
energies toward prohibiting what he
considered a new Menace other narcotic
drugs - a 1923 he established the
International Narcotics Education
Association in 1927 he established the
international narcotics defense league
and he worked as this kind of moral
entrepreneur with State Department
officials with folks within the
Narcotics Bureau to build an
international drug control regime that
of course far outlasted the war on
alcohol and went forward in new
directions another figure of course was
Harry Anslinger who came directly out of
the prohibition Bureau and was appointed
by Herbert Hoover in the spanking-new
newly-born
Federal Bureau of Narcotics Harry Jacob
Anslinger distinguished citizen in your
dedicated efforts to combat the illegal
traffic in narcotic drugs you have
fashioned an effective organization to
pursue this objective you're noteworthy
achievements in this field have earned
for you the respect of the world
community signed John F Kennedy the
campaign shared logics they shared set
of
officials they shared institutional
spaces so the the Narcotics Bureau came
directly out of the prohibition Bureau
so in some ways you could argue that
that war never ended
after the war and alcohol the namely the
war on narcotic drugs
what kind of politician was Al Smith and
had it he kind of reconfigured national
politics
I think he's such a fascinating
personality Smith was a you know
three-time governor of New York he
himself came out of was an Irish
immigrant he was Catholic he started out
in the early 20s coming out of World War
one is relatively on this progressive
end of the political spectrum but his
reputation is national reputation
largely was built around the issue of
prohibition opposition I got a real
thrill when I saw the six big horses
coming along what the wagon load of
there he linked that opposition very
much to a wider ethos of tolerance
social tolerance he identified the war
in alcohol as an attack on immigrant
culture immigrant and Catholics as well
and he built a really sort of role
within the Democratic Party as the
leader of the standard-bearer for
prohibition opposition and in so doing
he drew an enormous amount of support
among rank-and-file ethnic immigrants
many of who had never voted before who
had not really been involved in national
politics and and who as a result by 1928
despite the fact that he lost nationally
nonetheless really helped to realign
party politics by bringing in this
entire new constituency into the
Democratic Party what happened to the
Republican Party because it seemed like
I mean as the country was
industrializing in urban
saying Al Smith through prohibition
opposition brings immigrants in that's
right but then the Republican Party
which had owned a lot of cities or run a
lot of cities they've started moving to
the kind of they did because a lot of
those who had been at the base of the
voting the voting base Republican Party
in cities places like Pittsburgh places
like Philadelphia even in Boston where
you had the Italian immigrants many of
whom were voting Republican same in New
York by 1928 they are increasingly
moving out of the Republican Party into
the Democratic Party because of the
issue of prohibition opposition and
because of Al Smith's leadership so that
cut that the Republican Party is
breaking apart losing those that's those
supporters who are increasingly moving
into the Democratic Party by 32 and this
is partly becoming obvious Lee there's
economic people but also how Smith
represented them in a way the Republican
Party was moving more towards an atavism
in the during the 20s well what they're
there is not yet economic upheaval
rights right which is interesting right
so the realignment that happens in 28
happens before the great depression
crisis and before the New Deal and it's
around an issue that the right
prohibition is identified as an attack
on immigrant ethnic culture so you could
say it's a kind of ethnically linked
issue concern over nativism concern over
intolerance that is bringing these folks
into the democratic party but it's also
a class tinged issue because it it is
precisely poor men and women who are
those who are sort of the subsets of
groups that are around which prohibition
is being heavily enforced what is the
lesson from the end of prohibition that
we might think about in any era of
criminal justice reform these
large-scale campaigns which many sort of
progressive and sort of well-intentioned
men women signed on to because they saw
the problem of alcohol for particularly
for poor men and women they saw the
ravages of addiction on the
groups they wanted to protect groups
from that those ravages and outlaw in
industry you know in order to do so what
it teaches us is that those campaigns
are going to be unsuccessful and that
the approach a penal and criminal
approach toward recreational narcotic
substances is something which is not
going to succeed and I think that's a
lesson which we we learned about alcohol
but we did not learn relative to other
drugs in fact that as I mentioned that
campaign continued and increasingly
focused on other drugs in 1937 we got
the marijuana a federal marijuana Tax
Act and the sort of effort to prohibit
other forms of narcotic substances so we
have yet to learn that wider lesson and
I think what we should take away from
this looking back on the war on alcohol
is that it hopefully can teach us
something about our current crisis which
is that
well no simple repeal may get us out of
this current crisis of mass
incarceration we need to rethink this
penal and criminal approach toward drug
addiction it is simply doesn't work we
need to find other approaches that focus
on harm reduction and and and not work
on these could you know we stopped
pursuing this kind of war against drugs
which has really failed hopefully we're
at the beginning stages of that we will
leave it there thank you so much we've
been talking with Lisa mcgerr who's the
author most recently of the war on
alcohol prohibition and the rise of the
American state thanks so much thanks for
having me tourism TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you